[Musique]
ouais je suis en train de me laver
attend on chante on de me laver les
dents je dois bien à béatrice de trappes
et je comprends qu'on avait les dents
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
les
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah ah
de tiko
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
stéphane peignier les jeunes qui est-ce
qui gagne qu'est ce qui dans la vie tant
les pandores arrivé au bon moment
pour l'instant ce droit aux 20 ans
il est centré centre qui fait peut-être
pour victor dos point de penalty et
c'est le numéro on
auxerre qui mène 1-0 et le ballon en
corner corner en avoir
en deux tirs deux tirs cadrés il y avait
ces bons d'achat
[Musique]
et
tangage
qu'à passer un grand moment de sa vie
avec notre cher avec che guevara com
vient de sortir un bouquin sur le tce il
est venu là se balader un peu sur paris
et écrire ses mémoires dont qu'il est
chez moi et on se retrouve on prend un
apéro chez mon vieux pote george gens
qu'on débarque c'est probablement le
plus vieux au bistrot du quartier
c'est là où gréco chanter après guerre
la mangue ouais c'est super bon endroit
salut tout le monde a ri car nous on
boira déroule ses taux comme toi qu'est
ce tu présenteras thierry ben je vais
juste récompense et dénis keita lerman
étaient présents l'ami reste avec moi
bonjour tient qu elle est bénigne
cochonnailles elle raconte un des
survivants de tuer vous êtes connu
commence rue de la havane dans le boulot
que je faisais dans quête sur les traces
du choc
ça a été ma dernière découverte c'était
la grande découverte
c'est à dire il m'a obligé je le
remercie qu'à ses dépens de livres quand
on casse des pans de murs 1 est
tellement il a densifié mika est parce
qu ils représentent 10 ans de combat au
quotidien près du che des le
débarquement du che avec les ânes du
grand pas
castro et toute sa bande et le 14
janvier 57
il rencontre le che lui il n'a pas 17
ans sa fiancée a été tué par les hommes
de baptiste et qui faisait la chasse aux
paysans qui était sympathisant de la
réparation
donc il a rejoint ladite révolution et
il est resté près du che jusqu'en fin
pendant dix ans éducation vécu après le
dernier de combat du tuée le 8 octobre
67 et il était avec le tchèque en lécher
s'est fait arrêter
abattre à battre non puisque les trains
2008 et l'été sans gaine neuf donc par
contre il était l'un des dix est l'un
des cinq y accompagner notre chaise dans
le ravin du jour en bolivie et le 8
octobre at il demandé la chose la plus
importante que che guevara lui a dit la
seule phrase ou quelles leçons et
retient la canada line il a beaucoup de
choses de phrase en mémoire y en a une
qui n'a vraiment marqué c'est que quand
un homme faut qu'un homme marche
toujours la tête haute et qu'il est sur
le front la marque du soleil ça veut
dire qu'il n'a jamais incliné la tête il
n'a une s'est jamais dégonflé et dakar
c'est vrai qu'en ce moment il ya comme
on dit
non non le rock'n'roll un che revival
oui c'est vrai c'est dû à quoi tu crois
moi une sorte de pollen du temps pollen
de l'histoire froid que la jeunesse n'a
pas grand chose à se mettre sous les
yeux dans le coeur je crois que le tce
est une étoile il en avait une sur
sondés rêver sur son béret basque
et c'est une étoile pour accrocher à la
charrue des jeunes croient que c'est un
personnage digne et très présentables
elles et qui compte dans le monde dans
lequel on vit rennais garde une image de
pureté il a il un christ guérilleros
marxistes été atténuée
il voulait pas souffert de la chute du
communisme en plus moi je dirais que non
seulement elle n'en a pas souffert mais
qu'il est il est le seul qui reste
vraiment d'aplomb et qui reprend sa
toute sa plénitude d'hommes après
justement la chute du communisme
c'est ce que ce que je pense parce que
là sur le monde est ce qu'on peut parler
beaucoup je pensais les communistes de
l'époque c'est-à-dire ceux du kremlin ne
l'ont pas aidé du tout pour ne pas dire
plus c'est à dire que c'est pas
seulement la cia c'est à dire les les
flics
de washington qui ont aidé à la soul en
décembre que ça peut se comprendre
puisqu'il avait déclaré une guerre
ouverte à l'impérialisme mais les
légendes du kremlin les russes ont tout
fait pour empêcher sa révolution de
fonctionner donc ils sont ils sont aussi
coupables loach est un humaniste et ça
dépasse ça dépasse le ca dépasse le
comique
il a son communisme à lui la sensible à
sa manière de voir les choses
c'était un idéaliste c'était aussi un
utopique il l'a dit lui-même quand il
quitte à paraître ridicule
enfin il essayer de faire accélérer les
choses peut-être un peu trop clair il
voulait se nomme nouveau été un sorte de
portrait robot d'un homme parfait il le
voulait trop vite
il en est mort enfin il est allé au bout
en bout de ses convictions il a cartonné
pour les autres il a même génial a une
chance que james dean quoi c'est à dire
qu'il est le fennec bon à 30 ans à être
laissée cette image servir du christ
aussi de l'autre des barbus à feu
réellement continuer ou est ce que le
choix final disparu les américains vont
prendre le pouvoir
le même temps que ses fidèles ou
american tradition catholique à partir
du moment où fidel ne se retirera il est
évident que les américains on mettre le
paquet pour rentrer dans l'île c'est la
fin de la révolution mahé série à la
finale de la révolution dit non non ça
sera pas la fin de la révolution
monsieur henné sur son peuple est prêt à
se défendre et pas se laisser marcher
sur les pieds et dix mois est ce qui s y
croit toujours à la révolution mondiale
est ce qu'ils croient à l'avenir des
prêts de la révolution à cuba tous les
départs s elle a révolutionné le monde
toutes les solutions mondiales
nous ne nous préoccupons de pueblo
qu'après kong social n'a pas l'airé
mondiale pense que chaque peuple qui
aspire à un changement social ne peut
pas renoncer à la révolution n'est pas
terminée
quand on sait qu'avant
défiant la révolution finira quand la
terre n'existera plus mais elle
continuera jusqu'à ce que cette terre
c'est ma terre est-ce qui est ce qu'il
pense
comment ils comptent peut comparer
comment on pourrait comparer disons che
guevara et jésus-christ qu'est ce qu'il
ya de commun qu'est ce cas de pas commun
c'était barrès et la coopération entre
chez elle christian seely condamnation
que subway nasser est possible guerrier
comparation est portée au japon le
christ est planté
bien sûr parce que ce que le tulle le
christ avait défini je retrouve beaucoup
dans les pensées d'une chaîne hi algunas
coach des violets layette de loin dans
l'explication
les iem de la libye il a lu la bible et
il s'est aperçu qu'ils étaient proches
en fait parce que le christ était un
grand révolutionnaire lui aussi compris
des loupés
leur plein et sa lecture lui a démontré
que le christ était le premier de
révolutionnaire donc l'ancêtre du che
une histoire quand il est parti au congo
c'est le sud américains qui décident
d'aller libérer l'afrique après des
problèmes quant à elle à attaquer il dit
bien sûr que c log le premier
sud-américain qui est parti en afrique
avec la volonté de libérer l'afrique du
joug colonial mais
c'était c'était quelque chose de pensé
c'était c'était quelque chose de prêt
tabligh
c'était une aventure comme ça c'était
voilà on a causé si paris la baie et une
énergie la hf primaire où la révolution
en afrique en amérique latine
edit ça s'éteint c'est vraiment tiré sur
le terrain dit que après son son
repérage en afrique avant de s'y rendre
là il apparaissait que il fallait porter
la révolution en afrique avant d'aller
vraiment là nue mais puisqu'il avance
également allumé 2,3 plusieurs vietnam
dans l'amérique latine d'abord l'afrique
passé par l'afrique avant d'aller
révolution qu'est ce qu'on y verra il
avait 30 ans et un homme de 30 ans qui
étaient cotées jeunes dans les années 60
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'il avait
comme manille n'était pas seulement un
demi dieu est ce qu'il avait comme
maniche pas fumer des pétards et prenais
de la coke et tirait des gonzesses parce
qu'ils aimaient les couilles tu as déjà
répondu c'était non pour les autres
coups venus demander si les tirs aient
effectivement des jeunes dans la vie
quotidienne au canada tunis qu'un
automate
oui nous intéresse un match intéressant
thomas vanasse fière d'être un mythe
auquel l'homme et l'homme ne
l'appréciait de voir son petit verre
comme tous les copains comme des hommes
plutôt les tavana qui cache la forêt
une forme modérée et non chez un homme
qui a acquis sur les familles dit
toujours avec beaucoup de respect ils
mettaient jamais les gens dans
l'embarras toujours avec discrétion mais
c'est un homme qui aimait tout le québec
n'est qu une salle à l'autre jusqu'à la
sq étaient très sérieux
louis michel rasle titre les victoires
les plaisanteries oui la pièta les
hautes alpes et repart avec la fiesta il
la regardait et participe pas trop non
il était d'abord en premier lieu c'est
en premier lieu c'était un mauvais
danseur nos pénurie d'eau par la mort il
avait une très mauvaise oreilles dont il
connaissait pas la musique comme bouc et
confond des abonnements est vraiment une
mauvaise orbite est l'ami des
participants mais pour rester bien avec
tous les copains il se désolidariser
jamais il restait là
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
chez nos débuts
le passé
eva et la paire djakichev
la famille quitte à catane où je ne
fallait pas que la fesci tard
[Musique]
kita
m
allez
[Applaudissements]
pascal
m
mais
c'est toujours assez bas
et le lourd ça tombe bien comme je
m'occupe du musée imaginaire la télé ça
me plaît beaucoup c'est une expérience
toute nouvelle alors avant tout de suite
j'ai un cadeau pour toi de la part de la
ligue de saint-andré jeu super gentil
gentil non bel et bien c'est avec ce
saint-andré bon je le regarde avec
plaisir
dis moi alors ils veulent pas ils
veulent pas toucher au télémac à la télé
dont celle là est ce que tu arrives à à
traverser ce milieu pour en table
en restant pur digne aux termes je crois
que ce qui est important c'est
faire respecter
c'est de prouver que une jeune fille de
23 ans à la télévision peut avoir un
autre rôle que potiche koala a des
choses à dire peut s'exprimer
correctement et pour faire autre chose
que portait une jolie robe je crois
qu'on peut et portait une jolie robe
mais ça raconte non seulement porté une
jolie robe mais également
avoir des choses à raconter intéressant
on peut parler d'autre chose que de mode
que de l'éphémère
s'appelle attendant et continue son
envie de continuer dans cette voie mais
j'ai d'autres centres d'intérêt à côté
est ce que tu te fais plus de mecs de bt
à la télé est ce que cette année pour
séduire les mecs
[Rires]
tu plaisait pas les mecs ne voulait pas
de toi et tu donc maintenant qu'à la
télé est ce que c'est plus facile
un petit appel à témoin je crois que je
suis encore plus célibataire
non parce que j'ai beaucoup de travail
tapez le temps non je suis pas très
disponible
je donne toi ton métier
non parce que je suis dit j'ai d'autres
tant d'intérêt que la télé je m'occupe
aussi de
écrire
je ne sais vraiment cerner les gourmands
mais ça avance et telus kolani poussette
il
et je crois que le travail d'écriture un
travail de ces liquidations c'est quoi
l'histoire
les romains ouais on marche un peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
ça
[Musique]
et
six mois alors est question en jeu
question gilles s'est dit épaté
amoureuse en ce moment
[Musique]
tu veux la vérité le mensonge en vérité
en vérité je suis amoureux d'une image
mais je n'ai jamais rencontré avant
sunstar que pas encore rencontré l'homme
de ta vie tu avais ni comment il serait
l'homme de ma vie
ouais
comment ils se promènent sur le pont des
arts le soir et puis il me raconterait
l'histoire de l'institut de france il
raconterait l'histoire du monde
[Musique]
et puis en même temps ce serait un amant
merveilleux donc voilà je crois que ce
serait la dichotomie entre les deux qui
m'intéresse
[Musique]
les historiens
chérie je ne viens pas à côté de moi
nansion c'est la première fois que tu
prends un but comme ça
j'en ai déjà pris une fois avec mon
grand père j'étais tout
et il a voulu me faire découvrir
ah bon et finalement c'est très amusant
parce que
il m'a parlé de tout sauf de paris
en fait il m'a décrit casablanca où il a
toujours été visité par être pas là
exactement
ça marche ça dure
ça marche les trucs où il faut des
écouteurs à il faut des écouteurs en
pleurant des écouteurs
c'est parti pour un voyage les écouteurs
voyage initiatique les écouteurs tiens
à
la musique elle vient mesdames et
messieurs bonsoir et bienvenue à bord de
notre cas nous commençons à présent de
retour de paris
vous vous rendez vous de la capitale on
vous rappelons qu'il est interdit de
fumer avant de n'être qu'un
ce soit
il y a
mon
mithra
armagh
féminines tu iras j'irai où tu vivras je
vivrai d'humour âge ce qu'on se dit au
peuple sahraoui est plutôt dieu serra
mondiaux l'éducation dans les écoles de
bonnes soeurs sa fédé
des filles un peu différent bien plus je
prends un bloc de glace je commençais à
sculpter et j'ai commencé à sculpter je
sens que c'est une forme masculine qui
va surgir de la terre et puis je suis
pas satisfaite je continue je continue
je continue et finalement je les
transformer en femme et je crois que
c'est ça ça me représente vraiment ces
jeux
sa part des petits akumu par des karez
par des paroles par des parle par le
temps qui s'écoule je transforme les
choses
je continue à faire des sculptures j'ai
beaucoup de rêves éveillés
ça ne fait pas des bandes et les mecs
qui souhaite tellement intellectuelle
mais non parce que je peux être à moins
de 5 avance trop
thierry non je te dis ça comme ça
nombre de bars que l'espace
c'est toujours mon 90 d arrêter de
prendre la pilule de quoi gens charmants
ya quelqu'un que j'adorerais rencontrer
ce serait vraiment mon rêve
julien l'a bien sûr la littérature est
menacée de différents côtés où elle est
menacée
d'abord par le désert voisin qui
prennent plus de place certains que le
cinéma
après beaucoup plus place la télévision
maintenant c'est un art aussi enfin bien
que souvent ils soient pas très bien
exploité mais il prend beaucoup de place
dans sibilité dernier bien sûr la
littérature voit son son domaine ce rêve
se rétrécit j'étais beaucoup frappé une
fois par une chose qui est maintenant
évidente mais c'est tout de même
surprenant au siècle dernier aux tentes
de la croix la peinture c'était un peu
la pente servante mais tout de même elle
passait après la littérature de la croix
illustré goethe illustrait faust bon une
fois je me suis je l'avais dit à breton
ça m'a frappé et bien breton a écrit
douze poèmes pour illustrer des watch de
miro on sait le poète qui écrit là pour
illustrer la syndique un renversement
dans les précédents ce qui est tout à
fait tout à fait curieux qui est quand
même assez typique de l'époque parce que
la peinture a pris une place
considérable par le nombre de gens
qu'elle véhicule c'est absolument sans
aucune commune mesure et que c'est que
le dernier
et puis ce qui compte beaucoup parce que
la peinture c'est aussi un marché parce
que il est blue et les gens parler les
chiffres astronomiques ktm des ventes ça
ça compte beaucoup aussi pour le pour le
grand public de même il est fasciné
qu'est ce que vous nous dites même est
ce que vous êtes des hespérides c'est un
seul alternant nous
mieux pas désespérée je constate qu'elle
s'est rétréci c'est un fait
puis elles se portent pas toujours très
bien je sais pas si c'est une grande
période de lecture j'en doute un peu
enfin semble pas que ce soit une période
exceptionnelle il ya toujours de bons et
très bons écrivains afin que ce soit une
grande période seconde demi siècle ce à
peu près sûr n'avait tout de même pas
nous dire comme à l'intendant vote
il faut toujours attendre au moins un
temps pour savoir comment les choses
vont se décanter
c'est vrai oui il est sûr que l'accueil
et étrangers par exemple qui était
assigné est assez assez limité la
littérature française ne tient pas la
place qu'elle tenait jeudi connu entre
les deux guerres par exemple mais pas de
comparaison possible
il ya un désintérêt de constater que peu
changé
vous savez il ya toujours eu une
interdépendance assez forte entre la
place historique d'un pays dans les
affaires mondiales même et puis la
formidable puissance si d'expansion de
sa littérature que la france a perdu
dernière grande guerre enfin elle est
descendue du rang de grande puissance
température subit quand même les
conséquences merci j
non
nous
[Musique]
ogone on savait bon ben oui non c'est
pas la peine de me faire son grand
sourire on dit 11h30 il est minuit moins
10 ben non non non non pas fumé quoi
hein
alors je fais quoi moi je suis une bonne
et je fais une poubelle sur je peux
attendre toute la nuit là tu en a rien à
[__] ou presque tête de la télévision
et bien leur là il peut se il peut se
les geler toute la nuit
11h30 je me suis sentie c'est à 23h50
est en train de créer des trottoirs
défoncés
non seulement ce serait en plus mais je
voudrais pas c'est moi je travaille je
fais un boulot je le sens je suis
rabattu dans son passé chez toi tu est
repassée monsieur chercher du site mais
que ce que c'était quoi l'essentiel
voilà en plus encore tu seras comme je
vous l'avais un peu d'alzheimer
il est passé chez les écoutes tu voulais
faire combien de temps avec ton émission
ambages cette ardeur tories minutes
hornbein de plus la page doha chez moi
alors rien quoi qu'est ce que c'est bon
détendu
via picasa se casse le mythe de tous
c'est bien voilà on est heureux on est
on se rend compte qu'on tenait mans
alors alors alors quand même pas dur de
respecter un horaire merde et ça s'est
bien passé ce soir ton spectacle mais
non ne part pas dans des questions
gentillesse et j'arrive pas à jamais oui
ça s'est bien passé la soirée était
belle jusqu'à ce que tu jusqu'à ce que
tu me [__] 20 minutes dans le sang
était content et oui les gens les gens
étaient contents les gens au moins il
était à l'heure les étonnants loin on
leur dit 20h30 au théâtre grévin
ils n'arrivent pas à 23 heures à 23
heures c'est fini ouais console ça
allait oui ça allait bien mais c'est pas
ton petit tombiez le toute façon être
acheté un peu bah oui j'imagine bien et
si une idée
oui si on allait au théâtre grenat
écoute je sais pas si tu le mérites
cinq minutes alors après gendre un ouais
on y va tout de suite alors tu traînes
pas tu ne mets pas tout une équipe bis
on passe pas chez toi on est d'accord
maintenant ça me va maintenant les gens
dont la jambe est d'accord norma irs
alors allons-y
tu connais le chemin ouais
allez
tu vois avec tes trucs tout près à
ces gens s'attroupent facilement mais
c'est ça qui me gêne c'est s'il te
comprends c'est que moi je je j'aurais
voulu qu'on règle ce compte entre toi et
moi qui nous manque
tu sais tu fous la merde tu vois j'aime
pas ça quand les gens nous regardent
seulement toi tu es un corrigé voilà ce
soir là
la table au bistrot si celui-ci relais
du mime et un mini tornade
voilà qui est déjà allé au musée grévin
pas vraiment non
la regardes tu espères y rentrer un jour
eh ben c'est pas en arrivant avec 20
minutes de retard tu seras ça tu fais là
dedans
ici mes tracts en anglais c'est qu'il
est jean impassible on l'appelle
l'impassible gens vrais gens impassible
gens ça te fait rien alors si tu veux te
regarder l'arbre ailleurs si vous envoie
tout le monde on voit la caméra cachée
c'est un défi comme je m'imagine c'est
comme la dame du lac qui passe une fois
grand gymnase ion le motif
[Musique]
si fort que je
je t'aimerai demain 6 2
trop de respect
ce que je
sache que je tour
je crois que tu me
que tu
[Musique]
le temps ci mais moi ma gueule
des sensations
tant qu'à des choses mais voilà voilà
voilà
la dépravation voilà voilà ad que c'est
des nus ça te plait pas mal ça ça m'a
battu reconnaît tout de suite
raymond devos pour ça tu vois c'est la
partie du musée où tu peux espérer être
avec tes frasques vient voir parce que
je vais te montrer une autre partie du
musée où tu seras jamais qui est une
vraie partie des musées bien par là
voilà où sont ils voilà par ici la
retient voilà regarde diderot voilà là
là là voilà l'endroit où tu seras jamais
entre diderot d'alembert un toit cas est
toi qui a écrit une demi-ligne dans ta
vie tu l'avais copier ou ce n'est pas
écrit ces prix le bruit c'est sa
relative à la volée tiens tiens tiens
pascal harlez voilà alors ça se passait
je viens d'un canton compte qu'il
n'avait plus dû dire les billets les
beaux mais on vous connaît un peu il un
peu rouge aux intérêts de la pêche ça
t'aurait mais ça fait ça alors je
cherche vincent perrot mais c'est
peut-être là nancy ii alors lui des
problèmes de peau un nom mirabeau je
sais que tu aurais pas fait long feu
toile monarchiste un royaliste truc
machin
voilà robert stone de france
notre bon pays voilà un très vieux aussi
faire avoue qu'elle est un peu pâle
maintenant maintenant que tu as vu le
bas annoncé c'est toujours ça qui
n'intéresse lui sert à rien
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
j'espère que tout ça t'inspire un peu
tard que tout cet incident un peu un peu
plus de baaba j'espère oui voila je suis
quand même un peu navré de constater que
je t'emmène voir des personnages
historiques puis toi t'es qu'une hâte
c'est de courir retourner voir claudia
schiffer quoi c'est à dire que tu
pourras jamais te décrotter de ça et en
plus ce qui est pénible je m'excuse de
te le dire ce qui est pénible c'est que
quand je t'en fais le reproche aux lieux
humblement aux lieux tranquillement à de
me dire ben oui j'ai un peu exagéré je
suis un peu idiot je suis un peu léger
je suis un peu frivole et ben non talent
est à l'air content de toi en plus un dd
voilà je te montre voltaire je te montre
pascal oui mais maintenant tu regarde
par terre mais c'est pour faire ton
cinéma c'est pour faire ton cirque en
fait y'a pas de rédemption possible tu
seras toujours attiré par les boîtes de
nuit les boîte à partouze la drogue et
les verres de whisky coca 1
j'essaie de te montrer dans des endroits
mettez ça et rien on te montre molière
teinte était en train de ricaner de
chercher du haschich dans ta poche jeu
dont on montre pascal tu étais en train
de penser aux fesses de claudia schiffer
que tu ne pourra même pas touché en plus
alors je comprend non seulement de nom
non seulement été dévoyé mais en plus tu
es mégalomane tu n'auras pas tout ça tu
ferais mieux de rentrer chez toi de lire
un bon livre
tu ferais mieux d'aller regarder une
bonne pièce de théâtre tu pourrais me
drai étudie un petit peu shakespeare
d'autres bêtes un petit peu de plomb
dans la tête banon quoi il faut que tu
sois là mais un machin 10h bah oui ça y
est je crois que j'en ai fait le tour et
les
le voilà qui recommencent à retourner
voir les espèces de drag kings queens
kling 1 dans les dents dans des boîtes à
300 mille balles le le whisky voilà
alors tu vas te plaindre après
évidemment dont on voisinage te regarde
d'un drôle d'air ben je le comprends moi
je serai ton voisinage aurait déménagé
depuis longtemps du mot branche monsieur
fait n'importe quelle émission de
télévision honte à proposer des
émissions culturelles c'est vrai vous
pas honte à proposer des émissions sur
l'histoire de france des émissions sur
la littérature non tarifaires des
émissions sur les whiskys les boîtes de
nuit les les trucs à partouzes de [__] à
un courrier champagne en rien céder rien
si je sais ce que c'est ça qui m'attire
dans ce qui t'attire vais te le dis
cette série parce qu'il attire c'est
leurs équipements
c'est le pognon et c'est hallucinant
nuit c'est que pascal évidemment il n'a
pas gagné beaucoup de pognon en
attendant la jsk sont tous les liens
avec sur le mari pascalien lui a
rapporté la parole sur tous les billets
pascal oui mais voilà les toits ce qui
t'intéresse dans pascal c'est le billet
de banque
voilà tu cours après et aujourd'hui j'ai
dû bien sur la scène d'un théâtre pour
quoi faire
eh ben pour chercher s'il n'a pas encore
de trois pièces de monnaie qui traînent
par terre
voilà c'est tout ce qui servira il ya
des fleurs remarque oui oui bah c'est
comme ça pas vu le spectacle tu vas me
demander pourquoi je te le dirai pas
t'as qu'à venir alors là c'est pas des
vraies fleurs tac à venir ça c'est ça
alors là tu encore un peu il n'ya même
pas payer son entrée avec tout le fric
que tu gagnes à produire des émissions
ici sur la une la deux l'a3 l'a12 l'a15
et tout ça monsieur ardisson veut monter
un empire il se prend pour un américain
dérisoire tu ferais mieux de te retirer
sur un petit coin de terre 1 avec ta
femme et tes enfants et vivre comme un
honnête homme en réfléchissant un peu à
boire un bon verre de lait le matin
manger une bonne galette de blé que ta
femme fera cuire gentiment dans un four
artisanal un bouton ou d'être là à te
remplir le nez avec je ne sais quelle
cochonnerie qui font que tu ne sais même
pas arriver à l'heure au moins deux
rendez vous qu'est ce que tu veux que je
te dise et encore je me retiens mon si
c'est pour aller se coucher oui mais non
non si c'est pour retourner
qu'est ce que tu vas faire mas d'azil
qu'est ce que tu attends
tu as fait du porno amateur voilà et on
y est voilà
et voilà pourquoi ils pensaient à
claudia schiffer et bien alors les
sujets ardisson ils sont diversifiées il
ya un type qui fait du porno amateur
un type qui fait du porno
professionnelle puis lendemain ces deux
types à c'est très différent ça nous est
deux teams qui font du porno amateur et
l'autre va passer professionnel un bilan
demain il a un autre gros sujet c'est
des professionnels du bassin je décide
de passer à maintenant pourquoi j'ai
envie simplement assez varié ça ça va
leur plaire à la chaîne un petit peu de
cul comme ça puis après ben qu'est ce
que vous avez 21 tipiff érotisme mais
amateurs ou professionnels un passant
s'est passé ça le sujet justement on
enquête un petit peu on se demande
voilà voilà les recettes d'aujourd'hui
tu veux venir
heureusement qu'il me reste si tu veux
venir françois c'est ce que je veux
venir je me suis tu commencé si je viens
je dois voir à quelle vitesse je vais
vous mettre tout ça en prison marianne
balle à un bras voilà ce qui est beau
moi je veux bien venir et puis leur dit
elle à la montrer la beauté d'un d'une
petite fleur de colza bon essayer qu'il
retrouve là un sentiment une espèce de
toutes petites pureté si c'est possible
maintenant ils font du porno amateur
parce que tu me dises à des gens qui
font du porno amateur aille à rien et
coûte au moins ici tu aura pris un petit
bain j'espère deviendra piétonnière
voilà tu peux l'air de quelque chose et
puis dans dix quinze ans va te dira oui
il ya autre chose
1 à l'aller
[Musique]
non
l'orphelin tout se passe bien
génial j'ai fait beaucoup de films comme
ça que j'avais beaucoup vraiment combien
70 entre 80 et 100 ha bon j'ai commencé
les ventes en bref canon en maintenant
tu as déjà fait sens et alors c'est
super ça te plaît trop génial à moins
qu'ils viennent du blé c'est vrai après
se plaint que tu faisais avant ses
secrétaires assistantes médicales et je
comprends c'est un peu plus rigolo quand
même quoi hein et commentés rentrer
maintenant tidiane hausse à bon non non
quelques anna sacré bon et à la salue
l'annoncé a appelé et je me suis
retrouvé dans un film de boules ah ouais
le lendemain
le lendemain c'est rappeler tout de
suite là c'est sympa parce que les
sympathiques comment tu t'appelles toi
marie et toi enfin là bon là c'est sympa
de se marier et mignonne mais il ya des
fois ça doit pas être si drôle que c'est
ainsi on n'a pas à se plaindre en
général
ah bon si on peut se plaindre des hommes
et pas des filles avant ouais les arts
en général ils n'ont pas tous des belles
têtes
ah bah oui il fait quoi ton je viens pas
donc les soirs il n'a pas dans le coin
il surveille nom de la compagnie sont
jaloux non je crois pas ça les fait pas
chier quand vous faites des filles mais
moi le mien je peux pas dire que ça lui
fait chier puisqu'il fait la même chose
tahar ben saada qui vient de débuter
fois qu'il ya des buts et quatre
mentions dont le cerveau par l'ebu la
maison quoi à la limite on évite non
répète pas non plus le soir on dort
c'est possible quand on fait l'amour
toute la journée pour son boulot de le
faire pour devrait être soi quand on
rentre chez soi
pas chez moi j'ai regardé par l'amour
dans un lit et moi trouvait seul avec
une personne je crois pas habité par la
caméra ou est-ce que tant lui sa maman
devant la caméra c'est tout ça fait plus
jouer en français devant la caméra j'ai
joué ça me fait plus plaisir et qui joue
et toi quand je me branle avant à ce que
je fais est très souvent va comme ça on
sait comment ça marche sur moi est à toi
ben moi je suis pas tout à fait
différente
rapaille a shit imid je vois tu vas pas
nous raconter comment tu fais la mort ça
c'est ma vie privée je pourrais pas la
quitter comme ça je préfère la garde
pour moi
les dire de plus
[Musique]
j'avais perdu le goût
eschau
sans avoir
aco
la naissance d
mesures prévient
poussière
chavan
[Musique]
si vous voulez
chaud
ou pour
[Musique]
puis 6
souffle
[Musique]
mais il
la joie
[Musique]
tous
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
levine a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez
un pouce bleus